>>Male speaker: Good afternoon everyone and
welcome to this episode of Friday Review of
Apps.
I am Reto Meier and I am
joined in the studio today by Fred Chung.
>>Fred: Good afternoon.
Hi everyone.
>>Reto: And today we're going to do things
a little bit differently, uh, we're going
to continue to try to work on themes.
So the theme for today's episode is News Apps.
And that's being liberally interpreted by
our viewers, as news and RSS
reading apps, so that's a lot of what we got
in the moderated queue this week so that's
a lot of what we're going to be
looking at.
What we're going to try and do is take a look
at some of the top voted apps from the moderated
queue, have a
look at them and see what we like and what
we don't like, and then right at the end,
I'm going to spend a little bit of time
showing you some of my favorite news apps,
and why they are some of my favorites and
see how they compare with what some of
you guys have nominated.
So I think we'll start off by providing a
little bit of context.
So I've put together a list of
what I want in a news app which would make
it my favorite news app.
So if you could put that on screen for us,
Ian?
>> Fred: Ahh....
>>Reto: There we go.
News app wish list.
>>Fred: Check it out.
[laughter] I like that list!
>>Reto: Any of these items which a news app
doesn't have makes me angry, as you can clearly
see on the graphic.
Thank you
very much Roman Nurik for your artistic skills
here in putting this together.
So, what makes a great news app?
For me, I need it to do a few things so I
needed to have no latency at start up, so
I don't want a splash screen, EVER.
I don't want to be presented with "loading,"
or when pulling down news articles,"please
wait."
Anything after the first
time.
I'll allow it the first time, seems reasonable,
because you can't load data before your app
has loaded at least once,
but beyond that, I want to see news, and its
freshness is up for debate, but I never want
to be presented with an empty
screen or a loading dialog.
I want to have great notifications.
I want notifications which are rich, as in
rich notifications from Jellybean, I want
them to be not too interrupting, so that they
just come up when I want them, and the content
needs to be relevant.
It needs
to be related to the things that I am interested
in seeing.
Breaking news, stuff where there's a really
high chance that
this is something I actually want to see.
And it's the same sort of thing for widgets,
you know, I want to have a great widget that's
resizable so I can leave it on
my home screen so I can make sure I don't
miss anything important throughout the day.
>>Ian: Whoa, hang on you guys, this is really
weird, we were streaming and now we're not.
>>Reto: Okay.
>>Ian: I have a start streaming button again.
>>Reto: Uh.
>>Ian: Let's do this all over again, … [shouting]
Woo Hoo!
[Reto and Fred laugh]
>>Ian: we'll get it right this time
>>Fred: Take two.
>>Reto: So, do we just start again from the
beginning?
>>Ian: [sings] Start again, it's a nice day
to--
>>Fred: So, did we not stream or what?
Or did we stream at some point?
>>Ian: Oh Shit!
Somehow it stopped itself and it can't, it
says it can't start broadcasting again
because it already ended.
Holy shit, what the hell?
This is so wrong.
Let's see
[long silence]
Oh okay.
Sorry everybody that was MY fault.
My fault, Ian Ni-Lewis admits that it was
HIS fault.
>>Reto: It's a shame we don't have a producer
cam today, I feel that putting a face to the
name and the blame would be
useful in this instance, you think?
>>Ian: You can find me on Google Plus.
>>Fred: In Circle Ian
[Reto laughs]
>>Reto: We'll be looking at a post mortem
for that in about an hour's time.
But in the meantime, can I presume that everyone
has been listening and viewing along since
the beginning?
>>Ian: Yes, you don't get a do over after
all.
>>Reto: That's a shame, I think everyone would
like to have, to see exactly how much I can
do this exactly the same way.
So
let's bring up my list of hopes and dreams
once again, if possible, Ian.
>>Ian: Okay
>>Reto: Excellent.
Where were we....so I was talking about notifications
and widgets.
So the other thing I want to have,
similar to that, is offline support.
I want to make sure that if I'm reading it
on public transport, that every time I go
in
of out of a tunnel or anything like that
>>Fred: Like when you're flying
>>Reto: Absolutely
>>Ian: Flying is a little more of a challenge
>>Fred: or a submarine
>>Reto: [laughs] Submarine, indeed.
I think, for me, it's not as important that
it be like completely offline but it works
in intermittent situations so that if I happen
to click on an article when I go underground
or lose cell connection or
something, it still works for, let's say,
five minutes.
>>Fred: Yeah.
>>Reto: So five minutes is a good time length.
>>Fred: That's fair.
>>Reto: I think so.
I also want to have something that is similar
to the experience I get when reading a newspaper,
which I
realize dates me significantly, but I still
kind of like that flow, of being able to sort
of page through news and see
what's interesting, see what catches my eye.
Some sort of narrative, some sort of category
browsing which lets me just sort
of jump between articles and continue reading
things which I think are interesting.
What else?
I don't want to read through
the whole list, you guys, it's been on screen
long enough, you can probably see it by now.
The only other thing I want to
call out is you know I do want to have fresh
data, so I do want to have background refreshes,
but I don't want it to drain
my battery.
So I noticed, after installing all the apps
today that my battery life went to twenty-five
percent within about
four hours of installing them all, so that's
a bad sign.
Harder to judge, sort of, when I install a
bunch of things at once,
but definitely an important thing for anything
that is going to stay installed on my device,
is that it keeps fresh, but
doesn't drain my battery.
So is there anything in particular that you
want to call out
>>Fred: That's a hard, hard balance to strike,
huh?
>>Reto: It is.
It is a tricky balance and that's how you
get the big bucks.
[laughter]
>>Fred: There you go, there you go.
>>Reto: Was there any of those items which
you particularly want to call out...
>>Fred: I'd like to highlight the fact that
an app would work well on different screen
sizes, as what we've been
advocating, would be very very nice, because
each one of us have multiple devices and I
would imagine it's not uncommon for
a regular consumer to have a little bit over
one device.
one point five to two devices.
[Reto laughs]
>>Reto: One and a half devices, absolutely.
>> Fred: One and half devices on average.
You have a phone with a smart screen and then
maybe a tablet, a Nexus 7 for
example or a ten inch device, so make sure
your app looks pretty nice and good job on
the "on air" sign.
[Reto chuckles]
Umm, yeah,shall we get started?
>>Reto: Let's get this going.
So to give you guys a bit of background, we're
not going to into as much depth as we have
in
the past on each app, we're basically going
to buzz through the five apps that we've got
installed and try to highlight how
it fits into that list that I showed you just
before hand, and then I'm going to show you
two of my favorite news apps and
see how they compare.
So let's get started, let's fire up Good News.
>>Fred: Let's switch to the tablet, Ian, please.
>>Reto: Perfect.
So, Good News.
Good News is a RSS reader if I am not mistaken.
So is this tied to the Google Reader?
>>Fred: It is.
It is tied to the Google Reader so when you
first launch it asks which account would you
like to associate
this app with.
So I went through that authentication process
and it automatically pulls down from my Google
Reader, lists
all my subscriptions, and all the starred
items.
Let's go into the starred articles, it shows
you a bunch of apps, but at
first glance it feels like it's so sparse.
>>Reto: It's very sparse, isn't it, yeah?
It's basically a white screen with a few things
on either end.
>>Fred: We're looking at a ten inch screen
and um, if that's the layout, if that's the
only one layout that you want to
do, at least put some margins, on the two
sides.
>>Reto: It feels very very cramped here
>>Fred: yeah, even better, obviously, would
be to implement the two pane version.
>>Reto: Mm-hmm.
>>Fred: The two pane layout for a bigger tablet
screen size.
>>Reto: It would seem like a pretty obvious
thing to do for an app like this where you
are going to be doing a lot of
navigation through lists of categories and
then trying to read the articles, so having
the two pane layout really could
simplify that navigation.
>>Fred: Exactly.
So there are different sources available.
Let's tap into CNN and I expect to see a lot
of Olympics
related news
>>Reto: [laughing] You should have gone to
the BBC if you wanted Olympics related news.
>>Fred: Oh that's right.
CNN
>>Reto: There you go
>>Fred: Alright.
>>Reto: Again, it's the same sort of theme
where you've got this massive amount of screen
and it's just a lot of white, with
very small amount of text and no, no images
at all.
>>Fred: Oops, let's go back to BBC.
Let's try to draw down to a particular article.
It's a one line headline, and if you
want to, I guess, go into the website, you
press the website or the detail icon but it
doesn't show you anything.
[Reto laughs]
>>Reto: So it's not immediately obvious what,
uh, how this app works and what you're trying
to do with it, which is, which
makes for an interesting sort of challenge.
It definitely isn't optimized for tablet devices.
If we switch to the phone
camera, you'll see that it's sort of a better
layout, if not perfect.
>>Fred: there it is.
>>Reto: Sorry, Ian, if you could switch us
across there and show the folks at home, perfect.
So you can see, it's
exactly the same layout, it's just that that
small paragraph of text here fits in a way
that sort of much more easily
readable.
They get that right, it's clear that the layout
here's been designed specifically for small.
>>Fred: It's more natural.
If that's only one thing that you can do is,
I strongly suggest, adding, like what I said
before, adding some margin,
to left and right to make it more natural.
>>Reto: Absolutely.
So let's switch back to the tablet cam because
I know the folks back home prefer the high
resolution
one.
Let's see, if we exit out and go back in,
do we have any latency on the first.
It opened straight back up to where
we were beforehand
>>Fred: Good.
>>Reto: Which is nice.
You can see down here at the bottom you can
see that it kicked off synchronization which
is nice.
Um, too early to judge how well how it does
in terms of battery life overall, but certainly
it gets the no latency solution
which is good.
One thing that it doesn't do, so you did the
initial sign in profile, so this was for an
account that
wouldn't have had a Google Reader account
associated with it.
Did it suggest to you a bunch of different
topics and sources
that you might be interested in?
>>Fred: I actually didn't go through its use
case
>>Reto: You had an account
>>Fred: I had an account, with some articles
associated with it, but that's a good suggestion
by the way.
>>Reto: So that would be useful, so then again,
you want that experience, so for all the people
who are going to download
this app specifically to read their Google
Reader articles … but for the people who
don't use Google Reader, and there are
probably a few of them, you are gonna want
to basically provide them with that sort of
newspaper content, like here's a
bunch of stuff that other people think is
useful.
That's definitely something I'd consider in
your flow, if it's not already
there.
>>Fred: That's great.
That's great.
And in fact, that's what the Google Reader
product does
>>Reto: It does.
>>Fred: When you first log on, when you are
the first time user, it actually suggests
a number of articles, so you don't
need to stare at a blank screen.
>>Reto: I'm going to turn the Wi-Fi off
>>Fred: So what are you trying to simulate?
>>Reto: I turned the Wi-Fi off and see how
we do offline.
>>Fred: All right.
>>Reto: Let's see if we can read this, so
we can, so it's actually downloading the content.
>>Fred: I can see the headline, which is nice
>>Reto: So that's fine, I mean it's new, it's
an [indistinct] so I wouldn't expect it to
cache the links, but we can at
least go through here and read all the text.
It doesn't have the images, but again, that
is probably a reasonable
compromise.
So we can go through here, find out which
articles we're interested in and we can star
them for
>>Fred: Future
>>Reto: Yeah for future reference.
That's interesting.
So I click here, it's actually allowing me
to select the mode for
it.
Read, Read List, and Starred.
That's a little bit counterintuitive.
I would expect that if I hit the star here,
for
it to just star it.
>>Fred:Boring, it's boring.
Either star it or not.
>>Reto: I think it is actually.
I think if I hit the star, it works, it's
if I hit it anywhere else on the heading that
it
goes
>>Fred: So it goes back to the point where,
you know, you want to lay out your app properly,
for a bigger tablet screen
versus a small screen.
>>Reto: Exactly.
So these touch targets are way too small,
I should say these touch targets.
So we want to make them much
much bigger.
As we can see here, they're using a, are they
using a view pager?
I thought they were
>>Fred: I swear I saw it.
I saw it briefly..
>>Reto: They are using a view pager but it's
seems very
>>Fred: What are you paging through is what
I
>>Reto: The different stories
>>Fred: The different articles within CNN.com
>>Reto: It's confusing
time out?
sorry?
>>Ian: oh
>>Reto: We're getting hand signals from Ian
and we're not quite sure what they mean
>>Ian: You're right, we haven't agree on the
hand signals, you're just supposed to shake
your head or nod like a
baseball
>>Fred: wink
>>Reto: excellent
>>Ian: Catcher.
No, I just wanted to mention that, two things,
first that, despite earlier promises, you're
spending a lot
of time on this particular app
[Reto laughs]
>>Reto: true
>>Ian: And second that we do have Steve from
Phandroid on the line
>>Fred: All right.
Android is up next
>>Reto: So let's move on, so thank you for
the heads up because we do tend to get a little
involved so, big highlight
here: It does work online and off line; biggest
issues is that you've got a huge amount of
white space so it doesn't create a
really immersive reading experience.
So you really want to think, about updating
this for tables specifically.
Let's move
on to
>>[together] Phandroid.
>>Reto: Phandroid News, because we have the
creator online with us.
>>Fred: I'm sorry, what's your name again?
>>Steve: I'm Steve Albright..
>>Fred: Glad to meet you..
>>Reto: Hey Steve, thanks for joining us.
Why don't you spend a couple of minutes and
talk us through the app, what should
we be looking at, and how closely do you think
it conforms to the sorts of things we were
talking about earlier?
>>Steve: From what you were talking about
early on, one thing the app does not have
yet is tablet layouts.
Um, it is
something we do plan on integrating in the
future, but currently, right now, we wanted
to make sure we got all of the bugs
out of the app before we moved on to adding
more layouts.
>>Reto: Sure.
>>Steve: I think it's just good
>>Fred: Let's iterate
>>Reto: I think that makes sense
>>Steve: It looks like a little bit of your
screen is getting cut off.
Oh never mind.
It looks like it is looking pretty
accurate to what I assumed it would be on
a tablet
>>Reto: So one of the things that I should
probably point out is, looking at it on the
tablet like this, as you say, it
looks like part of the screen is getting cut
off, and that's distinctly possible with our
AV set up.
But it actually does
highlight a good point, that you don't really
have any padding around the outside.
So if you have a look at our design guide,
it
will give you an idea of what rhythm your
app should follow and I think it's at least
a six pixel border around the outside,
I could be wrong on the specifics.
But what you've got now makes it look a little
bit cramped, so that everything feels like
it's almost falling off the edge.
So you just want to add a little bit of padding,
around each of your elements and around
the edges of your layout to make it feel a
little bit more comfortable within the app.
And you can see that at the top where
you've got your icon and the action bar, it's
that kind of level of padding where you want
to bring everything sort of in
and out, in the same way that the action bar
works.
It just makes things feel a little bit more
comfortable.
>>Fred: I also suggest looking into increasing
the font size a little bit.
Because if you are looking at the category
heading or the news starred, they are just
a little bit too small.
>>Steve: I do have where you can switch the
actual font sizes.
>>Reto: Oh, great!
>> Steve: [indistinct]
>>Fred: Let's have a look at it.
I imagine it's under the overflow menu
>>Reto: Font size, there you go
>>Fred: Let's check on the font size.
Great, tiny!
>>Reto: Let's make it huge
>>Fred: Tiny, small, large, huge
>>Reto: Whoa, that was interesting.
So was that, I take it that's a custom animation
you've put in there to shake the
screen when you've changed the font size?
>>Steve: It’s a pretty common shake one.
Most people use it for errors, error dialog.
I had to put something there so you
know that it's actually processing.
>>Reto: I quite like that actually.
It looks neat.
One of the things I wanted to point out, to
highlight specifically about
this app that I like, is the way you've handled
starred items.
I've seen this done a bunch of different ways,
and most
commonly, people will have a single list where
the starred items are at the top of that list,
so then you'll click something
on the list it will disappear from where it
was and move it to the top and that drives
me crazy.
Because it really interferes with your normal
work flow.
What you've done here is great.
I can star all of these,
and then they appear here in my starred list,
which I really like, so, you’re doing the
instant star, you get everything
highlighted and you straight away have this
list, and if I want to remove them, I can
take them off this list and they
disappear and that makes sense to me.
>>Fred: That's intuitive.
Good Job.
>>Reto: So I rather like that.
And it still keeps that nice simple interface,
and I assume that all of the news that you're
displaying within this app comes from Phandroid?
>>Steve: Correct, yes.
>>Fred: And I see the refresh icon up in the
action bar, but what's the refresh strategy
like?
Is it manual or is it
periodic?
Or how configurable is it?
>>Steve: What I do is, by default I have a
background service that runs every thirty
minutes,
>>Reto: Uh huh.
>>Steve: Now the limitations of widgets [unintelligible]
upgrade every thirty minutes.
I need upgrade my own service.
>>Fred: Right.
If you need to go more frequent than that
you need to implement your own service.
>> Steve: Some people like every 5 minutes,
but that's a little overkill for me.
[Reto laughs]
>>Fred: Right.
>>Steve: I'm like once an hour, but if I set
it with no options then I get people complaining
from both ends, asking for
>> Fred: Manual, right.
I think if you set a default, out of the box,
refresh frequency of thirty minutes, that's
a
frequency that is reasonable for a news site
like Phandroid.
>>Reto: One of the things that I talked about
at my IO talk this year was trying to create
something a little bit more
dynamic, in terms of setting that default,
so it's great that you give users the options
to choose, but one option you may
want to consider is sort of a dynamic sort
of back off to those updates, so that you
default at thirty minutes, but if the
user has installed the app but they've never
actually opened it, or open it very infrequently,
than that thirty minutes is
suddenly really aggressive right, because
you're draining the battery every half hour,
firing up the network, you know,
doing that download, and I only open the app
twice a day.
So what I basically recommend to do there
is that you keep track
of how often they open the app or click on
the widget or anything else and if you go
past the interval of your refreshes,
then double it so then okay, they haven't
looked at it in thirty minutes, so I'm going
to make it an hour.
They haven't
looked at it in a hour, so I'm going to make
it two, four, eight.
So you're just updating once a day.
And then as soon as
they do open the app and look at it you can
go straight back to that most aggressive thirty
minutes.
So you're trying to
balance their battery life versus the freshness
based on how frequently the users are actually
using the app.
It might be
something to look at.
>>Fred: That's a good tip.
>>Reto: Otherwise, the app looks good.
I think it's really interesting strategy you've
got with your advertising league.
Give people the opportunity to turn it off
if they want to, but make it clear that basically
by leaving advertising on,
they're helping to support the website, which
is, I think an interesting take on an advertising
supported app.
>>Fred: Right.
>>Reto: Can I ask you, what do you find the
split is?
Do most people leave it on? or do most people
turn it off?
Do you
have analytics run on that?
>>Steve: It really seems like a mixed crowd,
I mean, the hardcore Phandroid readers, they
like to support us you know?
I think giving the option to do it or not
to do it, it kind of encourages them to leave
it on.
>>Reto: Yeah.
It's like, you could turn them off but you
could help us out a little bit
>>Fred: It would be really helpful.
>>Steve: If you force them into displaying
ads everywhere possible, then you're probably
just going to get a lot of
complaints and no one to support you
>>Reto: That's true
>>Fred: Right, it's interesting that even
though you haven't specifically optimized
your app for our bigger screen size, I noticed
that the
ad size, they have adjusted themselves to
fit nicer on a tablet versus a smaller ad
unit on a phone.
>>Reto: So we fully, want to move on again
pretty quickly, but what I like is, the reason
why we don't have to spend too
much time is this is nice and simple, it does
exactly what you expect it to, does the update
schedule which we talked about,
do you have widget for this particular app?
>>Steve: Actually, I have three widgets.
>>Reto: Three widgets, nice.
>>Steve: One is just an icon widget, which
was first starting to mimic of what an icon
is, ended up removing the app title,
or the actual app name off the icon because
I couldn't get it to be perfect on one of
the devices, it was very difficult to
get it to look right.
The other two
>>Fred: It’s a stack widget
>>Steve: One is a news widget which has left
and right arrow buttons, and I obviously also
have the stack widget.
>>Reto: I do like a stack widget, so that's
showing us the first article in each of the
categories?
Is the number
representing the number of articles within
that category or what does the number represent?
>>Steve: The numbers are consistent with how
many comments are in the article.
>>Reto: Oh!
I see I see.
So it's each of the articles, because you
only have essentially one category because
all the
articles are on Phandroid and then the count
is for how many comments are for each article.
That makes sense.
>>Steve: If there are new articles which are
triggered by the background service, there'll
actually be like a little bubble
up by the Phandroid's logo, which displays
how many there are
>>Reto: Very cool.
>>Steve: Once you enter the app, you'll clear
those counters, or any notifications that
appear, and there new articles which
is different than read and unread.
>>Reto: Right, gotcha.
Okay.
>>Fred: That's great.
>>Reto: That's nice.
So like I said we should move on, but one
last thing I want to mention, in terms of
the background
updates, given that you've already gotten
a fairly aggressive timetable for those refreshes,
you may want to consider using
Google Cloud Messaging, so that you're notifying
each of your users whenever you get those
new articles so rather than
waking up every thirty minutes, or potentially
every five minutes for those really hardcore
users, presumably you guys aren't
quite publishing every five minutes yet, so
you can kind of back that off by just alerting
each of your users when there are
new articles to read, so then the device can
wake up and next time it's connected it can
go ahead and get those updates,
rather than sort of doing it all on the device
side.
>>Fred: Cool.
>>Reto: So yeah, GCM If you aren't familiar
with it, Google Cloud messaging was a re-released
version of Cloud to Device
Messaging which we released at Google, so
there's no quotas or anything like that, so
it makes it sort of perfect for this
sort of thing, where you want to blast out
a lot of messages to people.
>>Fred: And it supports batching, too.
>>Reto: Yes.
>>Fred: Which is awesome.
>>Reto: It's very handy.
Cool.
Alright, thank you very much for joining us
and I think we should move on to a couple
of
these other apps while we still have time.
>>Fred: Thanks.
>>Reto: Excellent.
>>Fred: So should we try Reader?
>>Reto: Yes.
Let's look at Reader HD, which if I'm not
>>Fred: Reader HD, what?
>>Reto: Mistaken, I think Ian represented
this is the moderator queue, is that right
Ian?
Is this an app you're a fan of?
>>Ian: Oh no.
My app is G Reader Pro, but I'm eager to see
if Reader HD beats it.
>>Reto: Oh, let's check it out then.
So this is again, this is an RSS reader, so
presumably, this is looking at the same
source
>>Fred: The same source as Google Reader,
provisioned with the same account.
>>Reto: Google Reader
>>Fred: It's got a two pane UI,
>>Reto: Excellent, excellent, we like that.
>>Fred: Which presents itself nicely on the
bigger screen size, uh, like what we're looking
at.
And on the right pane, on
the right fragments to be exact, you see a
bunch of news listings, with ability to star
an article, I assume.
The article
has been starred right.
Check box right here, I assume that is whether
I have read it or not
>>Reto: Shows if it’s been read, very nice.
>>Fred: The setup is pretty straight forward,
like the previous news apps that we looked
at today.
>>Reto: Very nice.
>>Fred: Rugby, it shows you an ad down below
in the news item
>>Reto: Do me a favor, star one of those,
Reticent Brits for example, give that one
a star, because I happen to have the
app open on a phone here as well and I want
to see it magically update.
>>Fred: Is it provisioned using the same account?
>>Reto: It is the same account.
>>Fred: Okay, cool.
>>Reto: Let's see if it magically does it.
[Both chuckle]
I rather suspect, oh no, it is refreshing,
so we'll see.
I suspect that we'll have to jump out of this
and jump back in for
it to refresh while we're doing it dynamically.
Let's try that.
Alright, not yet.
>>Fred: Let's go on, we'll report back
>>Reto: We'll report back, exactly.
So we'll switch back to the tablet.
>> Fred: All right.
>>Reto: Perfect.
In terms of the layouts, there's a lot of
white space, but it's white space that is
keeping it simple
rather than keeping it empty.
Umm, so we have all of the screen being taken
up, great use of the action bar, great use
of
the split panel, which Fred was describing
earlier.
It looks pretty good.
I quite like the looks of this.
>>Fred: It's pleasant.
It's a pleasant experience.
Let's go ahead and test the offline test.
>>Reto: Please, yes.
>>Fred: I just switched off the Wi-Fi, go
to the screen, and let's go back to Reader
HD
>>Reto: And again.
There’s no latency there, so that's definitely
a win.
>>Fred: That looks good and it looks like
news headlines are cached.
>>Reto: Yeah.
Nice, so you can go in and read the summaries
of each
>>Fred: Makes Reto happy.
>>Reto: It does.
It does make me happy.
>>Ian: Oh, I'm not going to be happy until
you can view original offline
[Fred and Reto laugh]
>>Reto: Let's see what happens when you view
original offline.
It's opening up the browser and failing.
So uh
>>Fred: We have Reto happy, not so much Ian.
>>Reto: Not so much Ian.
Let's see if Reader Pro
>>Ian: I think that Reto is not quite the
connoisseur of reader apps that I am
>>Reto:This is probably true.
I have to be honest, I do love Google Reader,
but I do tend to use that on my computer,
whereas when I am on mobile, I tend to sort
of read news from news sources.
>>Fred: All right.
>>Reto: Let's have a look at um, oh we don't
have news gReader Pro on that device, that's
interesting, so, gReader
pro, I have it on this one.
So let's uh, let's have a look.
Just going to scroll this down while I sign
in, we can just look
at this here, so you don't have to see that
email address.
It has the authenticator on the device, which
is nice,
It goes through, so this is interesting.
The Phandroid app did this as well, when it
first loaded it tells you what's new,
um, which is great, except for the most part,
people don't care.
So there is a place on Google Play to be able
to say
exactly what's new, and I certainly don't
have any objection to putting it up in your
overflow menu, but having it as sort
of the first thing you see, just sort of slows
me down.
If I click that icon, I just want to read
some news, I am not
particularly interested in what's new in the
app.
>>Ian: The other deal breaker is down under
notes.
>>Reto: "If you like gReader, rate us with
5 stars" Yeah, this is the thing, there's
been a lot of back and forth, even
within our own team, about how we feel about
apps that solicit ratings in Google play.
>>Fred: There's a pretty important distinction,
right?
Between asking people to rate your app, versus
asking for a very
specific rating.
>>Reto: Exactly.
I think we're pretty much all in agreement
that if you're specifically asking for a five
star review, umm,
even if you say, only if you like it, five
stars, that definitely crosses the line.
Me, personally, I don't like it at all.
I think, people know how Google Play works,
if they like your app and they choose to rate
it, they're going to do so.
Asking them
explicitly to do it, I don't think it's going
to give you a lot of value,.
>>Fred: It's uncool.
>>Reto: But definitely don't solicit five
star reviews specifically because, you know,
it's kind of not kosher.
So let's uh, let's close this, and move on.
So this is the general layout, so they've
got an action bar style bar along the
top, which I have to be honest, I'm not a
huge fan of because it's way too small so
you can see my finger in relation to
those buttons, as the camera
>>Fred: Custom action bar?
>>Reto: And they're all too small, and I'm
going to accidentally miss this and hit the
wrong thing.
It's also interesting
because this, see, I'm confused straightaway.
Because I expect these to be actions, I expect
them to be things which I click
and they perform something, plus should you
know add a new subscription, which it does,
>>Fred: It throws you to a screen that has
a different look and feel.
It's got a dark theme.
>>Reto: Yeah
>>Fred: Versus the white, light theme that
we were looking at.
>>Reto: Exactly.
So, it's kind of throwing me, and I can browse,
let's see dot net, something I did in a previous
life.
Go
look at Scotty Gu's blog.
So this is all taking a little longer than
I would like, because I'm an impatient person
so I'm
going to hit the back, I am not expecting
this to function as navigations, but as actions
but they're sort of working as
navigations so as I am clicking through these,
this is switching between feeds and tags,
which isn't what I'd expect,
alright.
So everything here I would expect to be an
action, and it's actually navigation.
So if you're doing that with an
action bar, navigation stuff should all be
on this side, next to the app icon.
So this is all fine, this is just the
overflow menu, with customized, which we're
fine with.
But again, I would think about how you can
put these, either as
tabs, or viewpager items, or something like
might make it easier to understand.
>>Fred: Does the app have viewpager in it?
>>Reto:It doesn't at this level, at least.
So I go through, read one of the articles,
and the articles themselves are, and
this is quite nice with the fade in fade out.
I thought it was fading in fading out, perhaps
it isn't.
Maybe I'm just too
quick.
But so these overlays are quite nice.
I guess this is going to let me increase the
size of the text.
But again, all
the touch targets are a little bit too small.
So it's good that they're not obtrusive, but
it's really hard to sort of
click them, and understand what's happening
there.
So, you've got it on the tablet now
>>Fred: I do, I do.
>>Reto: So let's open it up there.
>>Fred: Let's switch to the tablet.
>>Reto: Close this, it's the same opening.
>>Fred: Oh nice.
We have a two pane layout which is good.
>>Reto: Excellent.
>>Fred: Let's go to Engadget and look for
some stuff.
Left hand side, shows you a list of high level
titles and right hand side once
you've chose a title, a news source, you can
browse through the various news articles,
which is quite nice on the right hand
side.
And on the tablet, I'd say the touch targets
are a little bit, uh bigger.
>>Reto: Well this looks like a standard action
bar to me
>>Fred: Yeah, an action bar.
>>Reto: It looks like the tablets have just
gone with a regular standard action bar.
>>Fred: Right.
It does look like it,.
>>Reto: So it's much more to my liking.
>>Fred: So it just feels more natural.
A lot more natural on the tablet with the
bigger touchable target.
>>Reto: Let's take it offline.
We've done that to all the other apps, so
let's do the same thing here.
>>Fred: Oh yeah.
>>Reto: And let's see if Ian's favorite app
will actually do what Ian was hoping it would
do.
>>Fred: Alright, the moment of truth.
>>Reto: gReader Pro...
>>Ian: It may indeed be an optional setting,
so
>>Reto: Oh, okay, we'll check that.
>>Ian: You may want to look at some of the
settings, I completely agree with you on layout,
this app frustrates me to no
end, But I haven't had anything, I haven't
been able to find anything that has the same
features that this does.
The
specific things that I like are it has, if
you read long articles, the viewpager will
remember where you were,
>>Reto: Oh, that's nice.
>>Fred: Oh wow.
>>Ian: uh
>>Reto: So as we're scrolling through, let's
take a look at this Penn state scandal, that's
not long.
These are all short
articles.
So if we've got sort of multiple pages that
we're scanning and flick through it's going
to automatically move to
the right place in each of the viewpages?
>>Ian: That's correct.
>>Fred: Cool.
>>Reto: That's very nice.
>>Fred: Does it remember across devices, based
on your experience?
>>Ian: No, it does not.
>>Reto: That would be nice.
>>Fred: That would be awesome.
>>Ian: That would be incredible.
I don't think it actually remembers for very
long.
>>Reto: Mmhmm.
>>Ian: But that is not usually what I'm looking
for.
Usually what'll happen is I'll be reading
a blog, let's say, and flick
through to the next article and then realize
that I really wanted to see something in the
previous article, or I'll even
activate the viewpager by accident.
Which can be very frustrating if you are reading
a very long blog article to lose your
place like that.
>>Reto: Makes sense.
>>Ian: The other thing that it does is it
automatically mobilizes the text, I think
that might be a something you have to
set.
I've seen other RSS readers do this, but if
the blog that you're reading is one of those
where it just has just has a
sentence or two of text in the RSS feed,what
you can do is ask it to go and fetch the article
and cache it offline.
>>Reto: Which is exactly what we're looking
at on screen here.
So in settings, in offline reading, there
is an offline
usage which allows you to enable or disable
or switch for Wi-Fi only.
Downloading the article contents after you've
synchronized the headlines, so that's really
a very interesting feature.
I want to riff off this idea of being able
to
synchronize across devices, which I think,
from a games perspective, I think a lot of
us have been after this for a while,
so you could synchronize your progress, and
I would love to see this across more apps
like news, where, I just want to be
able to fire up the same app on multiple devices
so I'm reading it on my phone, and then I
sit down and pull out my Nexus 7
and be able to continue reading the same things
at the same place so that just feels like
everything is magically
synchronized to you.
So obviously you're going to need to find
ways to identify yourself on the various devices,
but for
users who do choose to do that, it would be
a real advantage.
>>Fred: That's a huge plus.
>>Reto: Absolutely.
So this is, this is nice.
Again I like the layout here, again using
that sort of white theme.
I would
point out, down at the bottom here where you've,
I guess these are filters, so we can filter
through these various items.
The iconography here, using the colors, almost
it feels out of place , compared to the rest
of the app.
I think it makes
sense where you've got the names with the
icons associated with each of the sources,
because they are something that people
recognize those colors for.
But for the most part, within the hollow theme,
anything which is sort of a menu item, or
an
action bar item anything like that tends to
be a monochrome icon, a flat monochromatic
icon . And I think that would look
much more in place.
>>Fred: Mmhmm.
>> Reto: If it was the same thing here.
>>Fred: Go look at the design guidelines and
go through them.
>>Reto: Exactly, yeah.
I don't think there's anything specific in
the design guidelines for it, because this
is quite a
custom thing, but I think it would just sort
of fit.
I also noticed one of your texts is getting
cut off
here"recommend---" and given that that side
bar is gonna be, you get to decide how big
it is, you probably want to make
that a little bit bigger.
But also keep in mind that, Roman pointed
this out for an app we were looking at I think
yesterday, is that we tend to, this almost
works like tabs, and it seems to suggest in
tabs you should either go for just images,
or
just text, rather than both.
In this instance, I think just images, as
long as you can provide icons which are obvious
enough, which I think in this case, everything
but recommended would fit into that category.
>>Fred: But for menu items, it's okay, if
there's
>>Reto: Yes.
>>Fred: enough screen real estate to include
both icons and text.
>>Reto: Absolutely.
>>Fred: Definitely keep that in mind.
>>Reto: So we have, I think, seven minutes
to go,is that all the
>>Fred: Let's go through your favorite apps
>>Reto: We have a couple more.
Yeah, I wanna look at my favorite apps, but
I think these last two, or at least News 360
is
an actual news app.
So I just want to bring this up real quick,
>>Fred: Let's go back to the tablet, Ian.
Thanks.
>> Reto: 360, no images in this category,
this means, see what this is going to do.
Interesting.
>>Fred: Oh, is it offline?
>>Reto: Uh, possibly, yeah.
That may not be fair.
It actually worked pretty well considering
it was offline.
Let's have a look.
Latest news.
"An internet connection is required to use
categories" but you have internet connection
now.
Okay
>>Fred: Take some time.
>>Reto: Take a little bit of time.
>>Fred: Ian, stop browsing.
Oh, there you go
[Reto and Fred laugh]
>>Reto: All right.
So, we've got an internet connection now so
we'll try it again.
So again, this doesn't have latency
at startup which is nice.
Rich display.
Showing us that sort of two panel option so
we can see latest news, so we can
sort of browse through each of these.
It's a little bit slow.
I would like for things to come up a little
bit quicker when
I change categories, so you'd at least have
the boxes and the headlines and some of the
text even if it takes a little bit
longer for the images to come through.
This is nice.
>>Fred: I like the color scheme, the overall
color scheme.
>>Reto: Absolutely.
>>Fred: It blends in pretty nicely within
the app.
>>Reto: Absolutely.
Nice use of the pseudo action bar, everything
on this side is a bit custom.
Not a fan of the settings
page, at all.
Or the settings icon . You’d be better off
here to use an overflow menu with settings
in there rather
than, find it in your inconsistent thing.
If we go back, search using the built in search
widget, so hitting back should
make the search widget go away, other than
make the app go away.
Just a little tip there.
So that's the 360 view.
So that's
the name of the app, 360.
Oh, that's a grim picture to have
>>Fred: It's like the differentiator of this
app
>>Reto: Exactly, it's kind of cool, we can
scroll through the pictures, and I'm guessing
if we click on one of the images,
we get the ability to read the article associated
with it.
That's actually quite nice.
And in the article view, we actually
have, it's obviously a very visually based
app where the pictures are a big part of what
you're looking at.
Ah, that's
cool.
Okay, that's having looked at all those other
apps, in the few moments we have remaining
I wanted to highlight a couple of
what are my favorite apps.
So one of those, particularly for news, is
News Republic.
Umm, I'm gonna, that's unexpected.
>>Fred: Maybe I was looking there
>>Reto: Must've already been using it.
So this kind of follows that thing that I
was talking about right at the beginning of
an app which is being able to help create
that narrative flow, which means I can just
open it up and start reading what I
think seems interesting.
So we have this quick tour explaining what
everything is.
You know, I'm, to be honest, a little bit
ambivalent towards these helpful screens,
they kind of feel like, apps should be obvious
when you open them up, You should
just, up, and start being able to click things.
Things should just happen, and you should
be able to learn from what you are
doing, particularly news, we've all read news
before.
>>Fred: And for News Republic, in particular,
they've done, it’s very very intuitive you're
right.
There are only two options.
You can either go through the news articles
or search.
>>Reto: Yes.
>>Fred: Right, so for the most part, these
functionalities are pretty self-explanatory.
So to your point, Reto, I think that
the tutorial screen is rather redundant in
this case.
Just because again, you guys have done such
a great job organizing
your UI.
>>Reto: Exactly, so let's have a look.
Let's go into a category, straight away, they've
got some interesting UI elements
there where you click on a category and it
does that sort of 3D fade.
>>Fred: Right
>>Reto: Which is nice, doesn't go on for too
long, which is important.
So we can see all of the articles here on
the left,
we go straight away, this is kind of important,
we go straight into reading an article, in
the two pane view, so we don't
sort of get the list first and then have to
choose an article before we start reading.
We straight away get to start reading
content.
I don't think there's a viewpager.
Oh, there is.
Excellent.
So you can viewpage through each of these,
>>Fred: As you view pages,as you view page
through, it synchronizes the carets.
>>Reto: So we can see straight away, and we
can navigate either way.
That's nice.
>>Fred: Cool.
>>Reto: One of the things.
So they've done, there's a couple.
For the most part it's a pretty standard news
app, I like
the layout.
I think it looks really nice, there’s a
couple of differentiating features which they've
done that I think are
kind of cool.
One of which is that you're able to, this
icon here, just on the top right, gives you
an indication of how
people feel about that particular piece of
news.
And so I click on it, it will tell me what
people's moods are, whether they
are astonished, pleased, indifferent, worried,
sorry, angry, there's whole sort of set.
We can say, well, I haven't read
the article so I wouldn't want to judge it,
and then it will tell you up here how people
are feeling so as you can see, as
we go through here
>>Fred: People seem to be indifferent.
>>Reto: Everyone seems to be indifferent to
pretty much all of this news
>>Fred: Maybe they haven't read the news today.
[Reto laughs]
>>Reto: Let's go to the top stories, that's
probably more likely to have some opinions.
Mmm, possibly not.
Ah, here we go.
We can see three people have an opinion on
this, most indifferent, a couple of worried
folks, but this is really
interesting because it gives you an idea as
we sort of scroll through it, what the mood
of it is, is this something that's
going to surprise me, make me happy, sad,
and then that helps when I am just sort of
doing my news browsing to decide if
that is something I'm likely to be interested
in.
So we can see how people are, pleased.
Which is nice.
The other thing I
wanted to highlight was this sort of 3D view,
which is kind of crazy.
>>Fred: That's cool.
>>Reto: And this lets me browse categories,
and so one of the big things about this particular
app is that it tries to
crosslink everything, if there's a particular
topic you want to read about, you can follow
that train through a bunch of
different stories the same way you would on
something with a feed.
So yeah, you can go into health, so here for
example we
can see that there's been a bunch of things
which have been highlighted so we can click
London twenty twelve, and it's going
to find us a bunch of news articles around
that.
We get that sort of Wikipedia effect of being
able to just follow the trail
of breadcrumbs.
So you can just keep reading for hours and
hours.
Let's see what the Sex Pistols are up to
I may be spoilering the Olympic opening for
myself and others so I shouldn't read too
much more.
So I really like that.
It does a lot of those things right.
One of the other things I wanted to show you
real quickly, let's see, I need to make
sure I don't have too many things open on
my other phone, because I need to use my real
phone for this.
There it is, so if
we switch to the camera phone, we'll see.
>>Ian: Well, I'll switch as soon as I know
you're not going to leak something again
[Reto laughs]
>>Reto: Where's the fun if we're not leaking
things, come on man.
Perfect.
Oh wait!
You shouldn't have seen that, no, I'm
kidding.
What we've got here is one of my favorite
things
>>Fred: Rich notification
>>Reto: Rich notifications
>>Fred: What is richer than android notification?
Rich notification.
>>Reto: So, I discovered this sort of by accident,
this morning when I was just playing around,
you know because I saw this,
and thought "I'd really like to read the rest
of that, but I don't want to open up the app"so
I just gave it a try and
dragged it down and 'boom' there is all the
information I need.
It even has the ability for me to share or
select my mood
right there from the notification screen.
This is really, really useful, I"m really
looking forward to more app implementing
these rich notifications and big props to
the guys at mobile News Republic for building
out this stuff so quickly after
their release.
One of the things I like about this app is
they tend to follow all our new stuff as soon
as we release it, so
for me, as someone who always has the latest
phone, the latest OS, I get to take advantage
of this feature straight away.
Thank you guys, I very much appreciate that.
Now, it has been a bit of a love fest, if
we switch back to the tablet.
We've
been talking about all the good things about
this app, one thing that I want to take this
opportunity to point out to them,
is that they do fail one of my tests, which
is the zero latency, pretty quick from the
Transformer Prime, but I get this
splash screen, and I get this splash screen
every time I load the app.
Which is particularly painful when I'm following
one
of their great rich notifications.
So they have great notification system, which
every time a news article pops up, it tends
to be something I'm interested in, because
you're able to customize what kind of news
you want to read, so it tends to be
something relevant for me.
And I'll click it and have to wait two or
three seconds while it loads past the splash
screen,
which kills me.
By the time that's happened, I'm bored.
I was just going to read it quickly while
I was waiting to do
something else.
So if you guys could figure out a way to remove
that splash screen and the associated latency
then I'd have
close to a perfect news reading.
>>Fred: I would suggest that they use one
of the techniques that Reto already mentioned,
to track to the last time the user
has entered the application and if it was
only two minutes ago then you can bring back
up the previous news items versus if
the last use was thirty hours ago, then you
might optionally put up a screen that spins.
>>Reto: That's really a very good point, which
I hadn't even realized, is that it doesn't
go back to where I was,
particularly if I'm hitting the home screen.
Like if I'm here, in the process of reading
through, ah, let's have a look.
If I go through and have a look at all of
the happy, friendly news, which if Ian puts
on the tablet, you'll be able to see,
that we've been able to select just good news
things which make me happy.
Yeah, everyone's happy, the stocks are going
up, I
know I am.
>>Fred:Yay.
>>Reto:So I'm in the middle of reading these
things and I go back to the homescreen to
do something else, to check what time
it is, and then go back in, I would expect
that to take to exactly where I was, but it's
dumped me back into sort of the
main homescreen of the app, and that makes
me sad.
So, yeah, that's definitely something you
want to work on as well.
Perfect.
So I think that's pretty much
>>Fred: All right, so we're
>>Reto:all the time that we had because I
went on at length over the first app again.
I'm going to need to learn
discipline, but that's all the time we have
today for our news apps.
Next week I think we are looking at recipes.
>>Fred: What are we doing next week?
>>Reto: Recipes is what we're looking at.
>>Fred: Some lifestyle apps.
>>Reto: I want a recipe app.
I want an app that lets me browse recipes,
store my own recipes, all those sorts of things,
and
I have not yet been able to find a great one,
so importantly, I'm going to be looking specifically
to pick out apps to
highlight which allow me to store my own recipes
and share them with other people, not just
apps that provide excellent
recipes.
So do check out the moderator page, and if
you have an app that you've been using that
you think is perfect for
this, please put them in there and we will
check them out, next week.
>>Fred: Sounds good.
>>Reto: Awesome.
Stay tuned, we’ve got Ian and Dan for the
Friday Game Review.
I believe they're looking at tower defense
games this week so that should be interesting.
They'll be on in just ten minutes.
So stay tuned, and we'll see you next week
same time, looking at recipe apps.
>>Fred: Bye.